[Applause]
pulling up to meet the driving force
behind Europe's hardline position on
brexit Boris Johnson entered the Alizee
palace to come face to face with another
charismatic strong-willed
image-conscious leader who prides
himself on standing tough Emmanuel
macron an immediate spark was evident in
the unstinting Parisian sunshine Boris
Johnson and president Makran were as
effusive about the anglo-french
relationship as they were critical of
each other's positions on brexit
becoming a backstop Yolandi the key
elements of this agreements including
the Irish backstop and not just
technical constraints or legal quibbling
but indeed they are genuine
indispensable guarantees to preserve the
stability in Ireland the commitment to
the indispensable guarantees of the
withdrawal agreement but a dampener on
those who had believed possibly wrongly
Angela Merkel had opened the door to big
changes the day before but Boris Johnson
showed no inclination of paying
attention to this pessimism I think we
can get a deal and a good you know I was
powerfully encouraged by our
conversations last night in Berlin with
our mutual friends a wry smile from the
French president who had appeared to
suggest that there was a chance after
all that the withdrawal agreement might
change so long as it didn't change very
much I can be very clear we will not
find a new withdrawal agreement within
30 days which will be very different
from the existing one it is just that's
what Michele Barney a has negotiated can
be amended while complying with the
integrity of the single markets but
Boris Johnson had his own trick up his
sleeve twice he confronted his French
counterpart over putting up
infrastructure on the Irish border in a
deliberate act of coding under no
circumstances will the UK be putting
Czechs at the at the frontier and we
don't think it's necessary from the
point of view of the EU to do that to
protect the integrity of the single
market both men seem to be enjoying the
confrontation look an optimistic
flourish that came amid signs of brexit
fatigue across Europe as countries
increasingly see no deal as a very
slightly outcome
in Berlin yesterday Angela Merkel
concentrated on relationship building
with Boris Johnson constructive dialogue
and injecting some sense of optimism
into discussions here in the alizée
palace president Makran and Boris
Johnson went straight for the most
difficult issue of all the Irish border
and how to police it on that there was
no sign of a meeting of minds at one
point President Makran ignored he seemed
like the hard man of the EU gang but the
body language at least suggested that
Boris Johnson was very at home in his
company after all tit-for-tat
point-scoring between British and French
politicians in public has been going on
for hundreds of years
Punch and Judy side is there always
there's always been this sort of
tradition of sniping now and then the
consequences of no deal would go beyond
what I would call the sort of background
banter it took 30 days for Boris Johnson
to meet his French counterpart as the
time came to say goodbye
they seemed suddenly inseparable both
men determined to show their enthusiasm
for the cameras Sam Cates Tiny's